Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
A lot of you may have just seen David Corenswet
Superman for Superman Legacy in various pictures
wearing Henry
Cavill Superman suit even before James Gunn cast
the new Superman.
There was tons of fan art featuring different actors
in Henry Cavill's Superman suit.
Just because nobody knew
what the new Superman suit was going to look like.
But James Gunn recently
revealed that David Corenswet did, in fact,
actually, where Henry Cavill Superman suit
when they were testing for the character.
So I'll explain why he had him do that.
He told a couple of funny stories about it, too.
and it wasn't meant to slight
Henry Cavill in any way or poor
saw it on the wound because of all the justice,
the actor recasting it basically the studio
kind of jerking Henry Cavill around before James
Gunn ever came along.
we also learn what's going on
with the brand new live action version of Supergirl.
It's going to appear in all of the upcoming DCU movies
in James Gunn's new rebooted universe.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
It's the beginning of the year as me posting this video
and there are so many big announcements
that they're going to be making
in the next couple of weeks.
But right now, you probably saw the ramping up
on production of Superman Legacy.
They're getting ready to start filming,
which is why you've been seeing teasers of the Fortress
of Solitude with James Gunn,
all the crew filming up in Norway in the frozen north.
Like, why would they need to go to the frozen north
for a Superman movie?
wait a minute. That's right.
But if you have no idea why, James Gunn, of all things,
would have David Corenswet Screen Test
to be Henry Cavill's replacement
as Superman wearing his Superman suit.
Just talking about it sounds a little bit nuts,
But in reality, it's a long standing tradition
for all superhero movies
just in general, at all studios, not just DC movies,
but Marvel, other comic book movies.
Any movie that requires a super suit of some kind
that costs a lot of money to make.
People have been doing stuff like this
for a long, long time.
One of the best examples is Henry Cavill himself
screen tested for his Superman
in The Man of Steel movie for Zack Snyder
while wearing Christopher Reeve's Superman suit.
It was Zack Snyder that specifically wanted him to wear
Christopher Reeve's Superman suit
instead of wearing Brandon Routh suit.
That's the
guy That's not only movie star,
that's frickin Superman.
So that was cool.
when he came out in the Superman outfit
and just stood there in front of us.
I was like, first time I felt like he was a movie star
on my set looking at him.
It was in his audition
mostly because that was Zack Snyder's preference.
Like he had fond memories of Christopher Reeve's
Superman, as you do, as everybody does, much more
so than Brandon Routh.
Superman. So it's really just a personal preference
kind of thing.
When they were auditioning for the Man of Steel movie.
in the same is true for all of their superhero movies
that exist in like a long standing franchise
where people get recast over and over again,
like the director of each new comic book movie or movie
that requires a special super suit will often
have the actor's screen test wearing the previous
suits from the previous movie in the franchise,
sometimes the last movie in a franchise
or sometimes older suits, like in the case of Henry
Cavill wearing Christopher Reeve's suit.
Notice how much smaller Henry Cavill looks
when he was screen testing for Man of Steel.
Like he got way, way bigger, way more small.
They even turned it into a special workout.
Videos like a whole big thing
when Man of Steel came out.
Do the Superman workout.
one of the other best examples of this phenomenon
in the DC movies
specifically was Christian Bale when he was screen
testing for Christopher Nolan in Batman Begins.
he wore Val Kilmer's Batman suit for that.
Even though George Clooney was the most recent Batman
before him.
I guess Christopher Nolan
didn't want to make Christian Bale or the other actors
that he was testing against for Batman
to wear the bat nipples.
That would have been sadistic, like,
No, no, no, you have to screen test for this,
but you have to wear the nipples.
in fact this is Christian Bale,
Kilian Murphy and Ian Bailey
all wearing Val Kilmer's Batman suit
because they were all screen testing for Batman Begins.
it's totally nuts seeing them in Val Kilmer suit.
Christian Bale and Christopher Nolan now
tell all kinds of funny stories about them doing that.
they said that on the day when they were filming
those scenes, the room where they were actually filming
got super hot.
So Christian Bale almost drowned in his own
sweat inside that costume because the technology
they used to create Val Kilmer's Batman suit was way
more primitive, way less breathable,
and just way less wearable
than the modern superhero suits that you see.
if you watch the Flash TV show
that there was an evolution of Grant Gustin
flash costume, mostly for practical reasons,
like the final suit that he wore
was meant to be like the most comfortable
and the most breathable,
as opposed to the original suit that he wore
that gave him all kinds of crazy neck problems.
James Gunn was also joking that when they were screen
testing David Corenswet for Superman Legacy,
he had trouble
fitting into Henry Cavill Superman's suit
because David Corenswet
is so much taller than Henry Cavill.
So he basically had to squeeze himself into that suit,
even though Henry Cavill is already huge.
You have to imagine them
pouring Henry Cavill into his Superman suit.
And then David Corenswet
being even bigger than that.
But if it wasn't clear,
David Corenswet will wear a totally different
Superman suit in Superman legacy,
like they're building a completely different suit.
That doesn't look like any of the Superman suits
that came before it.
James Gunn's also said that none of the fan
art that anybody's produce up to
this point has even come close
to what his Superman suit is going to look like.
So forget what you think is going to look like
because apparently nobody is even close to guessing.
he also said that even though they're going to finish
filming Superman Legacy
this year, he's not going to release any trailers
until next year.
And he's actively trying to prevent anyone
from actually getting a look at the new Superman suit
until next year.
But we'll see about that.
all but that at some point some tease or the new suit
leaks out somehow by the end of the year
or James Gunn just decides to release
an official picture before the end of the year.
That's usually how these things go.
they'll be like a potato quality version
that will leak out and it'll look terrible.
The studio will then release a nice shiny
HD version that just looks way, way better.
cellular, your clocks for that,
like wait for the crappy leaked version
and then the really nice shiny
one that comes right after that.
but the other really major Superman
legacy news is James Gunn is finishing
casting the brand new Supergirl
who will be in Superman Legacy.
We don't know exactly
what she's going to be doing in the movie.
I'm guessing it's going to be more
on the cameo level overall.
But James Gunn went on this big kick
about how important not stuffing in
too many cameos to a movie was.
in there's already so many characters in this movie.
So it sounds like whatever
Supergirl does in Superman Legacy,
it will be critical to the plot,
even if she's not in a ton of the movie.
in most versions of the Superman in the Supergirl lore,
the way they explain it is that Superman's pod
wound up arriving on Earth first.
Even though Supergirl was much older
when he was a baby.
whole idea is that Supergirl is
Father was sending her to Earth as well to guide Kal-El
when he was growing up, teach him what he needed
to learn about being a Kryptonian.
But because physics in their relative flight paths
caused his pod to land on Earth many years before hers.
He basically grew up on Earth, not knowing anything
about his heritage until much later in his life.
in it sounds like that's what they're going
with during Superman Legacy.
It'll be a version of that origin story.
Somali guests right now without seeing more footage
of the actual movie is that we'll see
Supergirl as part of Superman's origin story
when Krypton is getting ready to explode.
Like we'll see her on Krypton, also leaving the planet.
then at some point after the events
of the Superman legacy, then they'll actually
be meeting on screen,
having more interactions on planet Earth.
maybe, maybe at some point during Superman Legacy,
they'll reference Supergirl
as part also coming to Earth.
But I'm not expecting her to be really big
during present day because it sounds like
most of the problems
that Superman faces in Superman legacy
he'll be doing as the only super person on planet
earth is still alive.
you have to remember there's
going to be a lot of Kryptonian stuff
happening inside the Fortress of Solitude in the movie.
technically,
there is a lot of Kryptonian stuff on Earth,
but we might not have seen Supergirl
actually make it to Earth until the end of the movie.
Or after the events of the end of the movie.
but she'll go on to be the DCU Supergirl
that will appear in all the crossover movies
and the solo Woman of Tomorrow movie
that they're working on right now.
reportedly, it's
between Millie Alcock and Meg Donnelly.
I'm more familiar personally with Millie Alcock
because of all the House, the Dragon season
ones that she played the younger version of Rhaenyra
during the first half of season one.
She did a great job in the Game of Thrones universe.
I haven't seen too much of her other live action work,
but I think that she could pull off
a pretty solid version of Supergirl.
the funnier thing about Meg Donnelly,
if you didn't realize
or you haven't seen it yet,
is that she is actually voicing Supergirl
in the Justice League crisis on Infinite Earths movies
that are coming out this year.
There's going to be three of them.
Batman's right.
I don't belong here.
With Krypton gone, Mom, gone, I.
I don't belong anywhere.
so if you watched Crisis on Infinite Earths, Part
one, the movie version of the animated movie
you've actually already heard MacDonald
play a version of Supergirl.
in. It's so crazy
that she looks like she could play live.
Action. Supergirl.
I would not have thought that
just from hearing her voice.
I've already done a couple
Justice League crisis on Infinite Earths video,
so I'll post links down to the description below.
But generally between the two of them,
Molly Elcock is a much, much bigger star.
So right now I'm betting on her over Meg Donnelly.
But it's always possible.
James Gunn goes in a completely different direction
and I totally trust his casting instincts.
So if he does cast
someone else, I'll be totally fine with it.
Let me know in the comments.
Who do you want to play
that brand new version of Supergirl?
There's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
Henry Cavill Speak of the Devil.
Also just teased his new Warhammer series.
Click here for that
brand new Henry Cavill Warhammer trailer
and click here for that
brand new Justice League crisis on Infinite Earths.
Part two Trailer Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
And I'll see you guys in the next one!